tim cowlishaw joins me now on the Rich
Eisen show Tim I promise not to mute you
on this program okay welcome welcome
chase thank you sir you are welcome sir
the Dallas Morning News how how's the
fan base they're treating this is
everybody looking for the trapdoor
wondering when the Cowboys of the last
four years if not the last 10 12 20
years are gonna show up okay oh we lost
tim cowlishaw there when you get him
back Chris law you let me know y'all get
him back in the meantime I guess I did
mute him where is his cell reception did
mute him so I mean the Cowboys coming
into this game are taking on a team in
the Washington Redskins that have lost
nine in a row on the road that is the
longest streak in the National Football
League Alfred Morris they're waiting
we're waiting to see him come alive he's
had 18 rushes for 54 yards last year as
we all know he had a much better season
the Cowboys the last time they led the
NFL for the most wins at the end of a
week alone in first after week 10 in
1994 they were eight and one is Tim back
on the phone Tim you there Tim's back on
him yes I mean I'm here that that okay
it's much better sir how is everybody
there fair feeling about the Cowboys are
they over the moon are they looking for
a trapdoor there in the Metroplex I
think there's some trepidation peep you
know one playoff win this century people
have been through 13 and 3 and that
didn't go anywhere so they want to see
more but I think there's a real belief
that they at least have the right system
they're running the ball that takes the
pressure off Romo that takes the
pressure off the defense it seems like
something that could work they just need
to see it for more games so where do you
think the cowboys are going to wind up
this year well I mean I keep trying to
figure out who I think is better and we
can go i thought maybe Green Bay was
better than I saw a rogers limping
around a last night near the goal line
and what happened with that team so I
still think Seattle and San Francisco
in January I would put my money on them
but they obviously both have plenty of
issues to overcome and and quite
possibly would have to win in Dallas
given their records and the question is
though let's not sleep on the team
that's coming into the Jones Mahal in
six days I mean no they they are
currently six and one as well Arizona
and and in search of a win like the one
that Dallas came up with a couple of
weeks ago in seattle where everybody can
believe in them everybody i think is
still waiting to see if Arizona can go
on the road and and beat an opponent
they're not supposed to be and now
Dallas interestingly enough can serve
the role for them that's the idol served
for Dallas a couple of weeks ago that
isn't that odd for Dallas to be a
federal yeah yes I mean but yeah Carson
Palmer Andre Ellington at running back I
mean there's a lot of disbelief there
they're really good defensively even
with the guys have been art they seem to
always have four wide receivers all
numbered like one 11 12 14 15 who are
open so you never know who it's going to
be from week to week but yeah like that
that's going to be a that's going to be
a great noon game here next week so what
do we owe the balance on the offense is
it Linehan is it is it Jason Garrett
above it all who has been preaching to
Tony Romo about this style of handing
the ball off and giving some sort of
system where he's not checking out of
plays and taking some of the burden off
of him to what do we owe the balance on
the Oh indeed III think some of it I
think some of it does have to go to
Gareth people have said when he called
the plays they never ran the ball like
this but they did not have in all the
plays in two years and their offensive
line two years ago it was nothing like
this one so I think it all just kind of
came together that's the three from
three first-round picks in the line a
quarterback who in the summer played
very little in Oxnard and and played
very little in the preseason so you're
going to be
cautious and a defense that looked like
it was just going to be terrible again I
mean all those things would say let's
shorten the game and run the ball and so
I have to think Garrett and rent a hand
you know figured this out together with
help from the fact that this defense
still look terrible in in Oxnard and
it's all it's all worked out amazingly
what's it going to be like for the
Cowboys fans to see colt mccoy in a
Redskins uniform mr. Texas never worn
himself tonight yes representing my alma
mater well one would think just as he
did in Cleveland no I mean I looked he
he can get the ball to two wide
receivers somewhere on the field who
have hurt this team a lot through the
years now the shawn jackson did a year
ago but he's at big games against dallas
pierre garcon the last receiver to have
a hundred yards receiving wide receiver
against dallas in the 15th game last
year so but but the thing is called
McCoy's always gotten hit a lot and he
was a fumbler when he played in
cleveland so he has to stay away they
can't give Dallas points if they don't
do that I think they can hang around the
game the way the Giants did last week
and make it make it at least
entertaining but I don't know that we
can expect the time from from young cold
well what I'm just saying is that we all
know how rabid the fan base is for the
Dallas Cowboys is there going to be any
sort of tugged emotion seeing Colt McCoy
I mean so many people in that state
rooted for him still root for him love
him we'll never forget him I I think
that goes away pretty quick Mike you
know I don't think they cheer much for
Griffin's when he comes here from the
Baylor fans and surely this more Texas
fans but I now Texas had so many issues
that people aren't really inclined to
show up in big numbers and say how great
Texas football is University of Texas
football so there'll be a few but but is
there will be needy outpouring of people
wearing burnt orange today how do Cuban
and Jerry Jones get along cuz I mean
Cubans taking shots at the NFL every
chance he can and we all know what you
know Jerry Jones stands for so out of
those guys keep ya they actually get
along okay he takes out to be
fell he doesn't take shots of Jerry he
always praises Jerry and in fact he said
you know you know as far as the you know
forty thousand texans fans of 49ers fans
Cuban just said it's the law of
unintended consequences you build this
massive wonderful stadium and and
sometimes those things happen but they
personally although they're very very
different they've never had any kind of
big dispute over anything now now Cuban
is is still jealous of the NFL attention
but i think is his idea that the NFL has
got an oversaturation problem that's
hard to sell with them in a league where
they play 82 games and potentially 28
playoff games yeah i mean and and that's
the thing that i have an issue with then
that's one of the things that i love
about the NFL playoffs tim is that the
playoffs are just like the regular
season it's one a week sometimes even up
a short week if let's say you play on a
sunday wild card weekend and you got a
saturday game on divisional weekend
those things happen in the NBA or the
NHL are you seeing in the in Major
League Baseball right now once you're in
the series in baseball you do get
similar to the regular season where you
play back-to-back games but in the NBA
sometimes you get 34 games that take two
weeks to play right and you never have
that in the regular season in the NFL
just immerse you get the end for the NFL
wild-card games to the NFC and AFC
championship games is less time than
some of the first film series dead yeah
I know so yeah and it but I think you
can make that argument if you know the
NFL picked another night to go to or if
they went to 18 games and we're just
dragging people off the field but you
know they haven't done that yet so I
think it's kind of a fake argument so
seven and one you think the cowboys go
to tonight do they get to 81 do you
think they take care of Arizona no in
the short week it will be six days for
them I would think right now no I have
to pick them to lose somewhere in this
stretch and I'm not going to pick them
to lose to jacksonville in london the
week after that so you know I could see
you get through tonight but then Arizona
you play a team that can stop the run a
little bit and then can defend your
receivers and has as you pointed out
something to really play for it to try
to get people attention because they're
still under the radar at six and one so
I think next week's gonna be very tough
thanks Tim appreciate it enjoy the
monday night game and we'll see you on
ESPN as well as the dallas morning news
pages hey thanks for it's appreciated
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience